book project is about goals seeing
around 1800 and it looks at can't a girl
show from now on these three authors how
they just talk about can't wrote a book
about goals and so I look at these
philosophical texts and then I look at
how they intersect with contemporaneous
optical technology is specifically the
magic lantern that was used to stage
ghost shows in dark rooms you know
something free cinema in a way and then
I look at gothic novels from the same
period which were more popular in the
late 18th or the 19th century where you
also have of course Coast operations
costly operations that are terrifying
and shocking so I look at those two
beefeaters gothic novel it's German
philosophy and technically
you